[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen und soziales
werden
ich stehe hier im süßigkeiten paradies
und zwar in der größten schießwart
abteilung in unserer region
hier gibt es wirklich alle schokolade
bonbons kaugummis gebäck und kekse
schokoriegel fruchtgummi pralinen
[Musik]
alle früchte chips
salzstangen popcorn und viele viele mehr
[Musik]
viele marken kennt ihr natürlich bereits
schon vielleicht gibt es auch einen
lieblings cache seine
lieblingsschokolade oder ein lieblings
fruchtgummi was ihr habt und jedes jahr
kommen neue snacks und süßwaren auf den
markt snacks und süsswaren welche trends
verfolgen aber auch welt hat die zum
beispiel glutenfrei vegan laktose oder
fruktose frei sind oder einfach nur bunt
und anders sind manchmal richtig inhalt
auch ganz gleich aber die verpackung ist
einfach anders und cool gestaltet es
gibt so artikel zu weihnachten zum
sommer zu oft zum frühjahr zum muttertag
und auch zum valentinstag und es gibt
wirklich jedes jahr immer wieder neue
ideen aber habt ihr erst einmal gefragt
wie diese produkte im supermarkt in
einen supermarkt im handel soll ich
sagen
ecuador muss sieben markwort kommen aber
habt ihr euch schon einmal gefragt wie
diese produkte im handel und somit in
den verkaufsregalen landen aber
entscheidet darf klar es gibt schon
gewisse produkte und marken die haben
sich bereits etabliert aber wie sieht es
denn mit den kleineren unternehmen mit
dem start ups aus wer entscheidet das
wusste er dass 90 prozent aller artikel
auf der strecke liegen bleiben das heißt
dass von zehn produkten wirklich nur
eines langfristig im regal landen
ich bin dieses jahr zum zweiten mal in
der jury des sports für die rundschau
der lebensmittel
die rundschau der lebensmittel ist das
fachmagazin für alle einkäufer der
lebensmittelbranche der suite ii ist
sozusagen der of the seas waren
industrie
hier werden produkte gekürt die
innovativ und besonders in sei es im
geschmack in der rezeptur in der textur
oder auch in der verpackung und hier
werden nur neuheiten ausgezeichnet und
im handel oder empfohlen
dieses produkt beispielsweise wurde
letztes jahr von uns mit dem switch
award ausgezeichnet kühne kennen die
meisten von euch vielleicht von diesem
produkt her von den kunden aus dem glas
oder auch von anderen produkten und wir
haben das produkt gekürt und ins micky
ward verliehen weil die marke einfach
einen ganz anderen weg eingeschlagen hat
und wirklich mut bewiesen hat was
richtig innovatives geschaffen hat
[Musik]
ich habe mich zusammen mit linda der
chefredakteur der rundschau für
lebensmittel und einigen anderen
experten auf die suche nach den neuesten
trends und innovationen dass man den
mystery gemacht und welcher ort wäre da
besser geeignet als die größte
süßwarenmesse der welt der del in köln
die jedes jahr stattfindet
[Musik]
kennst du die geschichte das ist ein
sächsisches belegt sind
warten auf dem gelingt
liga
[Musik]
minute
great food ist auch eigentlich so eine
spannende geschichte welche schokolade
oder da waren die sommer die sommer
international schnell grund immer total
bundestag hat seine geschichte total
erfolgreich und man sagt ja dass es die
gar nicht mehr gibt wären jetzt mal
gucken ob solche einfachen schokolade
schokolade hätten wir nein oder das ist
unglaublich das letzte einhorn sozusagen
der last weil sie muss man was man
wissen muss da waren 150.000 total
schnell verkauft ich glaube innerhalb
von weniger als zehn minuten gab es nur
online war der halb dieses jahr her und
es ist unglaublich dass noch eine
einhorn schokolade gibt müsste ich auch
nicht der tag zu ende gesehen
diese die wir jetzt gehandelt im
internet die das ist schon gesehen ist
brutal abgefälschte war so von außen
kommen um direkt ausverkauft war
ungeplant wusste ritter sport na ja so
ganz ohne so ein ding was direkt weg den
potenziellen märkte nehmen
die kommt wahrscheinlich irgendwo die
handbewegungen chip
[Musik]
mal
also ist hier wirklich sehr viel neues
entdeckt viele neue trends auf alte
sachen neu aufgemischt und absolut also
viel verpackung zum beispiel fand ich
total schade ich freue mich riesig dass
die jury durch zu problemen weil sie
sagen wir sehen uns beim city oder
antesten durch los geht's
[Musik]
neben
wir sind die ziehung frankfurt airport
conference center und hier wird jetzt
gleich die jury sitzung stattfinden da
freue ich mich natürlich sehr drauf
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich wenn
überhaupt in der jury und wer
entscheidet was die besten innovativsten
und leckersten süßwaren sind hier sitzen
jetzt die experten aus dem bereich
süßwaren
das heißt es sind die experten fürs
marketing für den geschmack aber auch
für die sensorik der lebensmittel und
die rundschau für lebensmittel die hat
die verschiedenen süßwaren hersteller
kontaktiert und die dauphiné ihre
produkte ein schicken die wir jetzt
gleich probieren werden jetzt kommen
gerade die letzten produkte an und das
heißt es geht es los kommt mit
[Musik]
ja ich bin's allee in 28 davon zwei
kinder und mit borat verheiratet und
seit fünf jahren betreibe ich einen
youtube-kanal sallys welt heißt er und
ist auch europas größter food kanal mit
fast 12 millionen videoabrufen im monat
und ich freue mich hier dabei sein zu
dürfen ich war auch letztes jahr schon
dabei und fühle mich auch zwei geehrt
also ich muss auch wunderschön und ich
bin hier auch eher aus der
endverbraucher sicht mit dabei weil ich
einfach jeden tag viele viele kommentare
bekommen
ich weiß was bei den leuten draußen bei
den zuschauern gut ankommt und lese
jeden tag hunderttausende von e mails
und kommentare
und ja bin gespannt darauf was es
wirklich dieses jahr neues zu entdecken
gibt letztes jahr war es schon richtig
schön und ja mal gespannt
aber manches was zu kalt ist haben ist
schmilzt nämlich das eis zu werden also
das eis vor ziehen damit wir das noch in
seinem ordentlichen kriegszustand
vermiesen
[Musik]
was hier aussieht wie das vogelparadies
ist in wirklichkeit harte arbeit wir
sitzen hier von morgens bis abends und
probieren etwa 120 süßwaren und snacks
in 28 kategorien wichtige indikatoren
sind hierbei der geschmack die sensorik
die verpackung die innovation das
herstellungsverfahren und natürlich auch
das unternehmen an sich welches
eventuell mut beweist und neue wege
einschlägt
[Musik]
gut an diesen tomaten dass das ein
startup ist aus berlin das nämlich ganz
engagierte leute die sich selbst die
obst und gemüse retter nennen und die
eben überzähliges obst sachen die
plötzlich reif geworden sind weg müssen
vom großmarkt einkaufen und dann dürfen
und zu einem leckeren natürlichen schutz
machen
deswegen bin ich geschützt als besonders
beeindruckt haben mich die chips die
tomaten chips und die apfelschnitze weil
die eben auch ohne fett richtig schön
knusprig werden
das kennt man ja so eigentlich nicht
also gerade bei dem format hat man jetzt
nur wirklich 100 formate und er war das
eigentlich das also knusprige chips
dabei rauskommt das fand ich sehr schön
vor allem auch für diejenigen die jetzt
sich nicht gerade eine ganze tüte chips
rhein ziehen möchten sondern einfach so
ein bisschen gesündere alternative
vielleicht auch aber trotzdem viel
geschmack drin haben also das muss haus
oder in fett frittiert zeit und musst du
dich zu sein
[Musik]
ich bin aus verbrauchersicht der
auffassung dass dieses ein riegel ist
der insofern mit der kategorie ein
bisschen bricht und weitergeht weil er
eben wieso mahlzeiten dann sagt es also
wir sind kompakt müsli was auch sehr
satt machen kann
dem einen oder anderen mag es vielleicht
schon ein bisschen groß portioniert
erscheinen aber man hätte wirklich
vielleicht meine vernünftige alternative
zu einer süßigkeit und muss ich kein
müsli anrechnungen das finde ich
tatsächlich neu und insgesamt auch sehr
liebevoll gemacht mit den verschiedenen
varianten sehr mühevoll und das ist erst
mal überzeugen
[Musik]
das ist also für mich ist das produkt
worauf konsumenten gewartet haben aber
ist das fair trade thema oder die aber
es ist egal ob biologisch wertvolle
palmöl ohne soja und blumenfreunden bei
dieses produkt kauft an herzlich
vielleicht bekannter einer tief
fairtrade er gibt auch bio da kommt auch
die ganzen segel und da gibt dann auch
das geld dafür aus jemand der
normalerweise immer das übliche nutella
kauft der kauft es einfach für uns da
haben wir haben es auch aber bei uns
gibt es dann auch nur am wochenende
das heißt ich würde dann jetzt nicht
kaufen und zu sagen okay gibt es die
gesunde alternative weil gesund ist es
ja auch nicht ich mache da steckt ja
auch schokolade drin zucker fett
gesundwerden apfel aber man nimmt ja
dann eben als süßigkeit als
brotaufstrich das darf man dann mal also
vom technologischen gesichtspunkten
betrachtet ist dieser lebkuchen weil er
vegan ist richtig gut gemacht
es ist sehr sehr schwierig und er saftig
und wenn man es nicht weiß es wird man
es nicht vom normalen konventionelle
gruppen unterscheiden können und bei
unserem kindergarten zum beispiel haben
wir gerade ein beispiel diana die
grundsätzlich nie mit essen darf weil
sie diabetes hat die hauptrouten und
verträglichkeit die muss auf alles
verzichten steht dann immer dabei
kindergeburtstagen jeder darf kuchen und
torten und süßigkeiten essen und die
darf man nichts essen das heißt es war
einfach mal eine schöne alternative sie
kindlich aus kleines süßes kekse und die
können das ist dann eben auch essen
also ich finde es eigentlich ganz schön
viele alternativen
die kinder produkte im bereich wenig so
honig tropfe so was einmal möglich die
kinder vom aussehen und steckt mir auch
gut und ich kann mir vorstellen dass ich
es auch sehr gut schmeckt riecht ein
bisschen komisch aber schmecken tut's
tor
das muss ich ehrlich sagen aber vom
regal steht und alt und hat würde ich
für meine kinder immer lieber so was
nicht
da habe ich ein besseres gewissen das
hat man praktisch diese brause und das
weingummi vereinbart und so wie du schon
gesagt hast du auch mal in dieser
geschmacks explosion im mund und man
kann abrutschen darauf weisen
genau wie gefällt auch an der hohen
brause das geschmackserlebnis gar nicht
aufhören dass es nicht nur rundherum
sauren geschmack hat sondern dass sie
moral dramaturgie sich immer weiter
entfaltet und man quasi bis zum ende der
brause geschmack im mund hat aber ich
würde sagen genug brause wir essen jetzt
an eine kleinigkeit und zwar was
herzhaftes
[Musik]
super trap bei der kategorie kekse und
das haben wir hier die technik seit klar
jeder kennt glückskekse artikel ist
natürlich was ganz neues
dass er jetzt schwarze kekse drin für
leute mit schwarzem humor
guck mal was drin steht bei mir steht
bei deinem anblick müssen sogar tränen
weinen
bei mir steht dein herz zerbricht wie
dieser keks dein leben ist kein ponyhof
und du bist das signal aus zum mitnehmen
eine party zum essen gehen zu
verschenken es gab es ein paar
herausragend originelle sachen wie die
technik aber vieles verblieb auch
eigentlich in tradierten also es gab
varianten na klar line extensions aber
so richtig der hammer das war vielleicht
wirklich hiervon weisen dieses ja ist
aber mal überraschungs produkt der keks
ich hätte mir in richtung marketing noch
noch mehr humor gewünscht noch mehr pepp
hause als das volk sagt man eigentlich
nicht mehr sagen mehr originelle
verpackung mehr originelle bezeichnungen
in der kommunikation gilt deutschland ja
eben immer sowieso als ein lustiges land
der dass werbung angeht wieso sind die
engel mal lustig in die deutschen immer
sofort finden die schade weil manch ein
produkt eben vielleicht fand kleiner
versuchen kommen wer dabei eigentlich
darüber lebt dass es vielleicht ein
sponsoring macht oder eine special
edition ist da könnte man mehr rausholen
man muss nicht immer nur alles über ganz
neue geschmäcker und ganz neue produkte
machen dann kann auch manchmal eine gute
geschichte erzählen wie wir es eben bei
den fixen gesehen haben ist eigentlich
keine produktinnovation sondern ist eine
neue geschichte um ein bestehendes
produkt auf der
und hast aber wahrgenommen was es so
alles gibt also spiegelt das hier für
dich das auch wieder das ist so ein
bisschen innovations- los war auch die
messe und was würdest du dir wünschen
oder was findest du was eigentlich der
shopper der verbraucher die community da
draußen möchte ein hornist ohne diesen
trend ist es ein marketing thema jetzt
einige natürlich das ding ab reichen
aber vielleicht auch schon zu spät aber
siehst du da irgendwas was hier auch
völlig fehlt es wird jedes jahr mit dem
trend gehen letzte unter dem motto ist
dies sehr einfach und nächstes jahr
wahrscheinlich irgendwann das gerne
gehabt aber irgendwas anderes wird auch
jeder drauf springen aber es geht wie
wir freuen uns ein bisschen des
kommunikativen also ich war jetzt diese
es ist sehr cool wenn ich wirklich cool
vielleicht bringt ja auch mal eine
neuheit an und sagen mir sachen
wahlrecht kekse nächstes da gibt es die
tussi keks da sie nur zu einem
bestimmten thema wer füllt die person
aber vielleicht auch ganz cool aber
ansonsten marketing also mutiger sein
kann er oder sein
ich finde es auf der einen seite sehr
schön zu beobachten dass wenn eine marke
den mut hatte etwas neues zu machen dass
wir das alle sehr angenehm überrascht
honoriert haben mit dem preis nicht
vergeben und das fand ich sehr schön das
heißt der mut der marketingabteilung
auch gegen interne da sage ich mal
tradierte meinungen vorzugehen haben wir
hier preisvergaben honoriert das fand
ich sehr schön und sollte eigentlich
auch die anderen marken hersteller
mutiger zu sein auch im hinblick auf
einen möglichen preis das ist die eine
die andere schiene finde ich gerade so
ein forum wie dieser dieses forum würde
ich sagen lebt auch davon sage ich mal
die start up unternehmens zu
unterstützen
das heißt für die neue ideen haben die
kleinen geringen bekanntheitsgrad haben
noch einmal stärker in den fokus zu
rücken
es gab noch nie so viele innovationen
die sich bemühen um den innovationspreis
zu bekommen also diese diese fläche
wurde verbaut
gegenüber der vergangenheit auch hier
was mir am meisten wundert aber
eigentlich nicht die start ups haben die
besten ideen
warum haben die großen anbieter nicht
auch diese ideen warum ich sag's mal
böse deckeln die ihre marketing
abteilungen und lassen nicht mal
wirklich was neues raus die hätten die
kapazitäten die hätten das geld dafür
aber sieg limitieren das auf mainstream
und das finde ich toll ob es nun mächtig
sind oder die tomaten sachen oder all
diese neuigkeiten haben mich freue ich
mich am meisten
es gibt zu wenig
die sich auch gedanken machen wie ist
denn was hergestellt oder verpackt es
gibt in den usa viel stärker eine
bewegung die sich auch für ihre marken
interessiert die sagt der geschmack war
immer so toll wie kann da verändert
werden
und das ist vielleicht auch eine chance
in den sozialen medien die den leuten so
ein bisschen geschmack beizubringen das
kann natürlich in der hochwertigen weise
geschehen die besonders gute schokolade
aber das kann auf einer breiten
populären war das geschehen wo man sagt
mensch hier die marke das ist lorenz zum
beispiel die liebe ich die chips sind
die besten und so ein bisschen
bewusstsein beim verbraucher würde ich
mir auch wünschen dass er sagt mensch
das sind die innovativen die kaufe ich
gerne das mag ich gerne und ich bin
vielleicht sogar fan davon es gibt ja
nicht nur bei den großen marken wie
nutella es gibt viele nutella fans bei
facebook oder andere sondern hoffentlich
auch immer mehr bei den kleinen marken
oder sogar bei den regionalen marken wir
haben so viele tolle schokoladen die aus
berlin zum beispiel kommen die oder
seele das kennen sie alle das sind die
weißen mäuse seit über 100 jahren gibt
es diese weißen mäuse und er wünschte
ich mir eigentlich mehr bewusstsein von
den verbrauchern und konsument zu sagen
die kommt von hier das sind unsere
weißen mäuse die und sonst keine okay
die kosten paar cent mehr
aber die kaufe ich mir und dieses
bewusstsein zu fördern das sehe ich auch
als meine aufgabe
und übrigens auch als die aufgabe von
anderen sozialen medien unterwegs sind
und sagen wir werben dafür vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr bewusst sein es muss
ja nicht immer das bio und so weit sein
oder das soja und so sonst kann ich auch
einfach mal denn dass man sagt die marke
ist witzig die finde ich gut dazu stehe
ich und ich glaube dass produkte die wir
heute gesehen haben wie die mutprobe
dann ausweg suchen weil sie produkte
sind die eine vitalität einen talk about
schaffen der an dieser klassischen tv
strategie vorbei geht dann ist lohnt
sich also auch ein tolles packung
konzept zu investieren ist lohnt sich
mal mit blogger zu sprechen all das ist
werbung also es geht auch mit ganz
kleinem geld das ist meine
auffassungen dazu für sich werbung zu
machen die bionade ist ein beispiel
dafür wie das am anfang ohne
irgendwelche werbemittel gelaufen ist
das ist ganz anders funktioniert
es gibt verschiedene wege zu werben und
verpackungs gestaltung wird dazu
vielleicht eine kurze zusammenfassung
zum zum werbeblock den würzigen gerade
versprechen dass die kollegen aus sagte
also werbung die verändert sich grad und
wird sich auch in den nächsten jahren
verändern das heißt viele werden auch
verstehen
dazu kommt dass eben die typische
fernsehwerbung endlich nicht mehr zieht
wenn ich jetzt daheim sitze ich habe
jetzt vielleicht zwei stunden freizeit
dann schaltet jetzt keinen fernseher
mehr ein weil ich jetzt wegen dem
spielfilm der 90 minuten geht nicht
zweieinhalb stunden investieren
ich schaue mir dann den fernen dem den
film online an über die werbung das
hätte ich dass ich einfach streuverluste
und die werbung geht jetzt so weit dass
er ihm sagt okay wir umgehen jetzt diese
streuverluste und gehen jetzt so
blockern zu youtube und einfach diese
anderen werbe wege wo man eben keine
streuverluste hat das heißt man hat
jetzt ein blogger der hat einen kochen
back kanal hat einen blogger der hat
mein beauty kanal und wird man dort eben
mit seinem produkt mag die leute direkt
vor sich mal die altersgruppe man hat
genau die zielgruppe thema eben braucht
und ich denke dass viele das jetzt in
zukunft auch verstehen werden und dass
es irgendwo hingehe noch geht
jetzt sehen wir nicht mehr in frankfurt
am flughafen sondern wir sind am
wunderschönen schloss eberstein in
gernsbach hier werden heute die suite
awards übergeben das die preisträger
warten schon drin
ich wollte ja eigentlich auch ganz kurz
die aussicht genießen ich glaube ich
chancen wir noch kurz in der minute an
nein das muss reichen denn die freien
träger warten auf uns ich werde jetzt
nach drinnen gehen und ihr dürft gerne
mit
[Musik]
ich freue mich riesig dass wir uns heute
hier sehen wir haben erst eine
weihnachts live sendung des swr wir in
zwei stunden zusammen packen dürfen das
ist eine logik spaß gemacht hat und das
war für mich sehr faszinierend zu sehen
wie also reihenweise der alten teenies
jungen lebens verstanden also kaum
zurück zu halten waren autotransport und
mit ihr leben zu wollen und tatsächlich
war die einschaltquote dann auch super
gut und der swr der normalerweise
darunter leidet dass die zuschauer alle
älter als 60 jahren ist das hat er auf
einmal richtig gejubelt zuschauern also
das ist wirklich ein millionenpublikum
damit die erfolgreichste in europa in
diesem bereich also das ist wirklich was
du da geleistet hast wie bist du dazu
gekommen
du bist doch eigentlich lehrer ja
eigentlich bin ich lehrerin aber ich
habe irgendwann gemerkt es gibt keine
richtigen back & koch videos für die
menschen zu hause machen immer nur
konditoren oder köche die da im
fernsehen sitzen und die machen das
alles auch ganz gut aber eben nicht so
einfach so dass man es daheim vielleicht
alle verstehen könnte und deswegen habe
ich gedacht ich schnappe mir meine
kamera habe die auf den kappen darauf
gestellt und dann den muss kraft
gebacken und das war so dass start von
cellestis und das ging einfach so ab
dass du gesagt hast damals der pause
wurde sofort geklickt ja ich hatte dann
über nacht tausend aufrufe und das war
natürlich schon verdammt viel also ich
habe mich total gefreut und youtube hat
mir dann gleich die partnerschafts
anfrage geschickt möchtest du youtube
partnerin werden und ich hab das dann
bestätigt habe gar nicht verstanden hast
alles passiert und dann habe ich einen
monat später mal wieder ein video
gemacht dann zwei monate später und so
entstand das ganze und es war wie so ein
rad und hat angefangen verlauten und
wurde immer größer ja ja und das ganze
mit irgendwann
auch da ist ein florierendes unternehmen
25 mitarbeitern bald werden es noch mehr
ihr habt ein fernsehstudio ist kann man
das heute mit dabei also das ist
unglaublich explodiert in ganz kurzer
zeit was ist meins wie das heißt es
schon über so ein süßes sage ja auf
jeden fall ich habe schon immer gerne
süßigkeiten gegessen jetzt nicht in
massen
man sollte er auch sie es waren immer in
maßen genießen
ja ich bemühe mich ich habe das schon
immer gerne gemacht aber ich finde auch
dass die snacks jetzt auch das ist
natürlich ziemlich häufig da waren und
viel vertreten und da schmeckt auch zeit
und ich bin seit zwei jahren gesehen der
jury mit dabei und wir starten mit den
bonbons da ist preisträger salons extra
cherry und hat vieles verziehen und
dieser welt heißt internet kommt
ja salons hat es geschafft einen bonbon
zu entwickeln der aus einer kombination
aus witzigem lakritz und fruchtiger
kirsch füllung besteht und die cremige
füllung 100 auch den würzigen geschmack
der lakritze wirklich gut ab herzlichen
glückwunsch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
echt super lecker der müsst ihr auf
jeden fall mal probieren
jetzt haben wir gerade wundervoll
gegessen hat wirklich super geschmeckt
wir hatten ein tolles bisher
und jetzt kommt noch ein bisserl und
zwar werden wir gleich eine schwarze
lange strecken und zwar mit dem
sternekoch band wärme essen war wirklich
bin da folge und einem rezept der
schwarzwälder kirschtorte schluss sie
bestellen
vielen dank ich nicht ist dass ihr
zusammen ja wir machen lesen kochkurs
sehr schön danke schön ist deutschland
danke
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt gleich drinnen die
schwarzwälder kirschtorte zubereite habe
ich jetzt hier noch zwei personen
abgefangen und zwar seit ihr die gründer
von der big box und ich bin ja jemand
ich schaue immer gerne auf die
zutatenliste und ich erkenne hier nur
drei zutaten drauf das heißt gemüse
gemüse in dieser box bekommt ihr dann
auf die idee überhaupt so eine box zu
machen
ja wir wollten einen neuen frischen wind
in die chips industrie bringen müssen
wirklich wie du sagt dass ich nur drei
zutaten und das ist das besondere sind
keine geschmacksverstärker drin also
wirklich nur die drei und was ist echt
wundervoll
das ist daher geschmack ist intensiv und
wie viel gemüse stecken da drin also 35
gramm boxer sind die 400 gramm frisches
bio gemüse was schon und bei lang lang
lang bei schwülen temperaturen
getrocknet wird keine zusätze kein salz
pfeffer kann keine aromen kein öl natur
pur nichts außer gemeinsam nichts außer
gemüse aber knackig was so ein chip
wichtig ist und da haben wir natürlich
die die edle box verpackung im moment
wohl so zu setzen dass es einfach
hochwertiges nicken ja vor allem kann
man ja auch die box einfach mitnehmen
also die passt auch in meine große
handtasche ist er frauen haben eine
große handtasche da passt die box immer
rein ins auto passt ihr ein
aber jetzt hätte ich noch eine private
frage wo also wo kommt ihr beiden her
das heißt aus welchem bereich stammt er
also kommt ja aus der
lebensmittelindustrie oder wie kamen sie
auf die idee also meine bräute
lebensmittel gut deutsch auf süße
lebensmittel technikerin und buhrufen
loben oder die jungs wissenschaften
studiert sie hat auch die idee so zu
sagen und ich komme aus mit
investmentbanking ich habe dann gesagt
ich vermag hier das machen das als team
bringt die richtigen skills mit um so
ein produkt aber auch zu platzieren cool
kids ab jetzt schon meine sympathie
gewonnen denn ihr seid im prinzip so
ähnlich wie muratow nicht ich hab die
ideen kommen aus der hauswirtschaft und
im rat der kümmert sich dann um den rest
muss es natürlich danke schön und
herzlichen glückwunsch
wohlverdient
[Musik]
das habe ich hier tatkräftige
unterstützung beim backen der
schwarzwälder kirschtorte die lehrer ist
nämlich heute mit dabei du bist eine
zuschauerin von mir geld kennt meine
videos schon und heute dürfen wir
zusammenpacken er dass du das gedacht
goal.com wir backen jetzt mal magst du
schon mal die böden auspacken hast du
doch aufgepasst weißt du noch wie es
geht
weißt du was wir machen eine ganze
eigene torte okay da alle ihre
schwarzwälder kirschtorte machen wir
machen einen ape escape hast du was es
ist
das ist eine nackte torte die braucht
man außen gar nicht einstreichen
nichts zeigt jetzt einen trick wir
nehmen jetzt einfach den spritzbeutel
machen das ganze umständlich sondern wir
machen einfach so machen hier so kleine
rosetten drauf okay du das noch mal habe
ich hier schon okay
[Musik]
das wetter
unsere neue interpretation der
schwarzwälder kirschtorte als naked kate
sehr schön und die anderen sind noch gar
nicht fertig beim speed world zeichnen
wir produkte und auch firmen aus die
neue wege einschlagen
jetzt stehe ich hier neben herrn
stollenwerk und frage hört erster firma
manner man erkennt ihr alle ist war vor
zwei jahren das erste mal in wien und
habe natürlich man bis jetzt habe ich
schon eingedeckt mit den richtig
leckeren waffeln und ihr habt den preis
gewonnen
der wortführer man kennt ja mama
eigentlich nur von den waffen die sind
ja wirklich schon furchtbar lag bestimmt
aber das müsse nicht einmal wirklich was
ganz ganz neues das was ganz neues wie
man später gibt es schon seit 1898 ist
überall beliebt jeder kennt sie haben
gesagt passt mal miteinander steht wo
sonst mache das immer auf mich
es gab bestimmt so einige die man heute
einfach mal er früh sich gebrüstet haben
das könnte sehr gut möglich sein
vielleicht ist ein bisschen klein die
idee gewesen was da so passiert ist
ich finde das sehr faszinierend wie man
auch diese süßen wirkungen bekommen weil
ich hinter nicht gerade einfach in der
woche so zuschneiden dass es so akkurat
dann auch in den nächsten kommt lassen
besondere schnell wirklich nicht über
haben wir das genau so hinbekommen ist
das original produkt was wir haben
also ist eine ganz schwierige technische
sache aber daheim bekommen und somit
anderes komme und meine müsli wasser
vegan ist und weniger zucker also
weniger süß ist
also ich war anfangs sehr kritisch
natürlich muss man alles kritisch
beleuchten erst mal kritisch betrachten
ich dachte das ist bestimmt viel zu süß
aber wirklich geht gar nicht also man
kann es wirklich super essen vom
frühstück wirklich viel weniger zucker
und auch mit viel von mir der tag morgen
ist gerettet
jetzt sind neben mir nach vater die
waffen für dich hier in der jury mit
super herrlich nicht nur dass wir uns
gewehrt haben sagte meine
davon abgesehen kann ist natürlich toll
sechs stunden lang zum naschen mit dem
eis angefangen über chips schokolade
lakritz forums es war eigentlich ein
kindheitstraum war ja dass blogs carta
auch als als hobby wenn man so will aber
schon mit mit einer gehörigen portion
interesse und das war natürlich toll
auch mit den experten wie die aber auch
den anderen experten zu sprechen und von
denen die meinungen zu den produkten zu
hören wenn es zum beispiel
besonderheiten gibt bei der herstellung
das waren wir zum teil nicht so klar
über bei den zutaten und ich
interessiere mich sehr für das marketing
und wie die produktverpackung ist aber
dass andere zuhören hat mich auch
wahnsinnig fasziniert ich hätte das noch
zwei tage mit euch machen
ich probierte sachen durch es nicht auch
ich hätte da war ein anderes als favorit
und das habe ich auf messen sagt glaube
ich noch größer ja man habe ich auch
immer cola light dazu getrunken was auch
nicht so richtig klug war
ich hatte echt bauchschmerzen zu haus
aber das gehört halt dazu
auf jeden fall dass ich auch schon
gehört ich glaube wir sind dabei auf
jeden fall ich muss nur noch üben sie zu
binden
es ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach
vielleicht machst du dazu meinen beitrag
in einem blog habe ich die pflege
vermisst die trägt heute den du da
wahnsinnig viel masse mit der beinahe
wir haben jetzt erst wir waren auf der
ism unterwegs wir waren auf der jagd
nach neuheiten
wir haben uns durchgewühlt durch die
stände dann haben wir uns getroffen
die ganzen einreichungen kam erstmal das
ist eine wahnsinnige order
da haben wir uns in frankfurt getroffen
haben acht stunden lang anschauen
ich erinnere mich an das ist wirklich
müdigkeit und so weiter aber es war
wirklich richtig richtig fand und jetzt
heute der abschluss bei supergeilen
wetter mit tollen tollen ideen tollen
stories also ich muss echt sagen ich
habe heute wieder einiges dazugelernt
das wahre macht einfach mega fangen und
ich freue mich schon wieder aufs mix
werde die das ganze wieder von vorne los
und wir werden wieder neue hätten schön
ist einfach super passt mir jetzt auch
super viel spaß gemacht
danke dass ihr mich auch schon fernseher
freuen uns auf die nächsten jahr auf
meinem kanal gibt es auch viele back und
kochrezepte und jetzt stehe ich neben
euch ihr habt ihr den regelhaft voll
gemacht
das hat ja auch mit dem bäckerhandwerk
kommen ja sehr sogar
es ist eine ganz traditionelle
verarbeitungs weise wären es wird eine
bäckerei entschieden die unsere regel
herstellt die werden nicht explodiert
die regel das heißt im klartext
normalerweise wenn die gepresst und wir
warten nämlich auch praktischen aus sie
werden quasi ausgeformt dann und dann
geschnitten
wenn sie aus den bereichen crm und
angepackt und das war uns auch wichtig
dass traditionelles mit modernem
irgendwie zu verbinden und so sind wir
nun auf dieses verfahren gestoßen oh ja
und dann mit ganz viel wandel wandel ist
meine lieblings zu tragen da freue ich
mich schon drauf
jetzt haben alle schon ihre torten
eingepackt und mitgenommen hier wird
jetzt noch sauber gemacht aber ich
konnte dich jetzt noch stoppen hier
steht ein doktor nehmen wir uns trotzdem
sagen sowie uns beide verbindet etwas
wir kommen hier weiter eigentlich eine
ganz anderen branche ich bin lehrerin du
bist genau und was hat dich dazu bewegt
in die lebensmittelindustrie zu gehen
ich hatte und so ist es neben ich hätte
in einem total lust meine aus teil zu
machen ich habe nur zwei jahre im
krankenhaus gearbeitet und wollte immer
mal was gründen was nachhaltiges was mit
lebensmitteln ist und am besten was im
unternehmen was irgendwie zumindest
einen guten wert schafft deswegen haben
wir dass der weg gegangen was
wahrscheinlich jetzt alle interessiert
darf ich fragen in welchem bereich zum
krankenpfleger
ja ich war zuletzt tatsächlich in der
notaufnahme
das hat auch ihre spaß gemacht aber ich
dachte wenn ich jetzt nicht gründe
dann werde ich das nie machen ok also
ich war ganz fasziniert beide sitzungen
am flughafen in frankfurt haben wir
wirklich viele viele produkte getestet
und probiert aber von euren beiden
produkt weist sehr überzeugt und zwar
haben wir hier einmal das buch ab hier
erdbeere mit aufgebaut und einmal die
tomaten schützt und was mich so
fasziniert habe es also ich kann es euch
auch mal zeigen sind diese tomaten check
da steckt ja wirklich 100% tomate drin
ja sie werden hierher gehört ein nur
luft getrocknet und am ende kriegen sie
noch ein spezial trocknungs klick so
eine viertelstunde und sind habe ich
wirklich kein thema aber trotzdem lustig
das ist halt das besondere das ist das
besondere er kennt ihr alle
wahrscheinlich dieser appell chips diese
letztlich sind wie gummi da kommt man
ewig darauf herum und diese tomaten
chips als ich noch mal partner mega
knusprig richtig lecker und was mich
heute fasziniert hat das wusste ich ja
bei der jurysitzung nicht dass er
wirklich ein ganz kleiner betrieb seit
also eine ganz kleine manufaktur richtig
also wir sind entstanden aus zwei leuten
dann waren wir zu dritt zu viert und
jetzt sind wir zukünftig haben meistens
noch ein bis zwei praktikanten die
mitmachen
das heißt mehr als sieben leute sind da
fast nie da wir machen alles selber also
was ist hoch papier anbelangt es
trocknen wie retten das obst wie
verarbeitendes dass sie gerettet das
obst war es schon völlig über den
reifegrad ist das nicht mehr verkauft
werden kann im supermarkt auf dem
wochenmarkt bekommt ihr das ist manchmal
gar nicht völlig über den reifegrad das
sind manchmal wirklich noch kleine
druckstellen und kein system über markt
ist alles glänzt alles so toll außen ist
es immer super schön ware die man kauft
aber was passiert mit den ganzen anderen
früchten die druckstellen haben die tat
haben den hagelschaden die lampen
meistens gar nicht im supermarkt
und sie kriegt der landwirt oft nicht
los und wir haben uns gesagt wir wollen
nachhaltig sein wir wollen viel retten
aus deutschland und deswegen kaufen wie
die beim landwirt wirklich tonnenweise
also wir haben bis jetzt schon 40 tonnen
äpfel gerettet und verarbeiten
und ihr habt ihr nicht nur einen preis
aufgestockt sondern gleich zwei das
heißt für die tomaten chips und für das
frucht papier und ich finde er denken
einfach sei vorbildlich und nachhaltig
und da finde ich muss man die produkte
und auch des unternehmens sehr
unterstützen
ich habe mir vorgenommen ich komme ich
in berlin mal besuchen und schaue mir an
wird das alles so bewerkstelligt
bist du dazu gekommen danke das mache
ich auf jeden fall bis bald ihr seht
dass es gar nicht so einfach für ein
produkt in den lebensmittelhandel zu
kommen
90 prozent aller produkte schaffen es
gar nicht beständig im
lebensmittelhandel zu bleiben oder auch
überhaupt rein zu kommen und ich finde
der suite die abordnung grad herunter
für lebensmittel schafft es einfach um
kleineren unternehmen oder auch startups
und kleine manufakturen zu helfen
wirklich auch fuß zu fassen gibt aber
auch großen unternehmen wirklich die
chance auch mal die anderen seite zu
zeigen
ich kann nur hervorheben ich find's ganz
toll dass ihr kleine unternehmen sich
auch beworben haben sowie die dörfer
manufaktur in berlin
die das obst und gemüse rettet und
daraus diese chips macht aber genauso
kann ich große unternehmen loben wie zum
beispiel mann aus wien die wirklichen
traditionsunternehmen sind die haben
seit jahrzehnten und jahrhunderten schon
ihre mama waffeln und haben jetzt den
neuen weg eingeschlagen und ein mann am
isley gemacht genauso kann ich aber auch
sagen startup unternehmen sind wirklich
herzlich willkommen und auch wirklich
toll sowie der ehrung mit seiner
biochips verpackung und die rundschau
für lebensmittel unterstützt gerade
diese unternehmen dabei sich vor dem
handel zu präsentieren das heißt dass
der handel überhaupt aufmerksam wird auf
diese neuen produkte und ich muss sagen
mir jetzt wirklich sehr gut gefallen ich
bin schon das zweite jahr mit dabei
freue mich schon aufs nächste jahr
und ich hoffe dass es euch genauso viel
spaß gemacht hat wie mir und ich fand's
hier vor allem wunderschönen die
location war wunderbar und ich bin schon
gespannt wo wir nächstes jahr hingehen
also bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]